pour accrocher chez vous dans votre
salle par groupes de seize ces élèves
vont se faire dépister contre le
coronavirus au collège saint-exupéry de
vélizy villacoublay
les tests salivaires sont arrivés cette
semaine c'est très très important de que
les élèves soient testés parce que ça
permet justement si un élève
alko vide et que l'on doit fermer la
classe de la ferme est beaucoup plus
rapidement avant que le virus ne se
propage
donc pour nous c'est très important
quarante mille tests seront réalisés
dans l'académie de versailles de manière
hebdomadaire 10000 concerne directement
le département des yvelines avec pour
moitié dans les collèges
les tests salivaires ont un avantage
ce qui est important c'est que c'est un
petit peu moins invasif que des tests
antigénique donc du coup ça suscite une
adhésion de la part des jeunes qui est
qui est plus grande et donc par là nous
arrivons à toucher davantage de jeunes
et leurs familles sont souvent aussi
plus enclines à
les autoriser à faire cet instant cet
établissement accueille 610 élèves pour
22 classes dont quatre ont dû fermer
avant les vacances
avec un peu de gêne parfois et de
sourires les adolescents se font tester
sur la base du volontariat
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
pour savoir si tout le monde est titre
pour savoir si tout se passe bien si
peut-être des cas dans le collège comme
ça ça a été évité la la contamination
déjà crashé dans 1 04 devant toulon
c'est un peu bizarre pas venu on en a
qui disent la fin pour moi mais c'est
désagréable on commet là sinon la
semaine prochaine les lycées de
l'académie de versailles seront à leur
tour concernés
cette fois ce sont des autotests qui
seront déployés